[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci comment vous avez vécu cette
journée de jeudi c'est bonsoir Cyril
merci merci d'être là comment on l'a
vécu
une scène de guerre
en plein Paris
au début tu sors dehors tu dis bon ça va
passer et puis ça dure 25 minutes et en
fait c'est inimaginable traumatisé parce
que vous avez fait parce que vous avez
fait vous avez touché quoi toucher
toucher toucher traumatisonnant toucher
une brasserie donc forcément brasserie
traumatisée non mais touché parce que
que devient le pays que devient le pays
ça que devient Paris on a 400 jours des
Jeux Olympiques
on a eu les poubelles quoi s'inquiéter
c'est quoi s'inquiéter bien sûr la plus
belle ville du monde les touristes
canule bien sûr
quand même parce que même si elle est
pas
c'est pas de sa faute tout ça c'est pas
de sa faute mais avant de soutenir les
grévistes c'est bien de se dire à la
limite on peut les comprendre les
grévistes on est tous concernés par la
retraite un moment ou un autre 80% des
Français les comprennent 70 en tout cas
sont entre soutenir les grévistes c'est
bien
il faut bien les différencier des
casseurs attention bien sûr dans tout ce
que je dis
mes soutiens te commerçants à un moment
donné soutient les on sort du covid bien
sûr on a des pijures remboursés
on Tintin des terrasses
et note d'EDF tout à l'énergie
tout d'un coup donc là aujourd'hui ouais
c'est compliqué mais tout s'accumule
c'est à dire que déjà c'était compliqué
avant les manifestations avant le
passage de cette loi enfin qui doit être
passée devant le Conseil constitutionnel
donc c'est pas encore faible mais bon
c'est à 99 % fait et donc le
l'utilisation du 49-3 et c'est vrai que
déjà avant c'était compliqué pour vous
et là ça rajoute encore quelque chose
c'est un truc de fou ça veut dire que
depuis vous avez fait les manifestations
des gilets jaunes et on était tous avec
les gilets jaunes mais forcément pour
les commerçants c'était compliqué vous
avez fait la crise du covid après vous
avez eu l'Ukraine après vous avez eu les
donc l'énergie
qui a augmenté maintenant aujourd'hui
c'est les manifestations un moment
comment on a un commerce en France et
dans les grandes villes ça devient très
très compliqué et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on voit de plus en plus de
gens qui ont limite un compte à rebours
c'est à dire qu'ils se disent moi
maintenant dans cette condition là et
dans ces conditions là je peux tenir
un mois un mois et demi deux mois il y a
des gens qui me disent moi voilà encore
trois mois comme ça et c'est terminé et
je vous dis vous ne vous rendez pas
compte de nombre de commerces qui
ferment dans toute la France
actuellement pour moi ça c'est une
priorité et on en parle ici que dans
TPMP les donneurs de leçons vous n'avez
jamais parlé de ça ils sont complètement
seuls ils comprennent rien et ils sont
plus occupés à faire des chroniques sur
nous qu'à faire des chroniques sur les
choses qui sont importantes et moi j'en
veux je vous le dis assez radios Radio
France ou des choses comme ça qui
doivent justement faire des choses pour
les c'est ils sont payés avec l'argent
avec l'argent
avec l'argent d'Alexandre avec l'argent
de tout public ici au lieu de faire des
chroniques humoristiques ou de faire des
choses comme ça faites des choses de
service public parce que les Français
ils ont besoin de vous et avec notre
argent on aimerait bien que vous fassiez
des émissions qui servent à quelque
chose et qui servent à aider les gens et
qui servent au moins à peut-être mettre
des des choses en place parce que faire
des chroniques et et se moquer du monde
provoquer des gilets jaunes parce qu'ils
sont moqués des gilets jaunes se
moquaient des antivacs se moquer des
gens qui votent pas Emmanuel Macron ou
se moquer de de de de tous les gens qui
sont qui se posent des questions ou qui
sont dans la rue voilà les manifestants
ils les aiment pas ils aiment pas ils
aiment personne ils aiment que ceux qui
sont tranquillement chez eux en train de
de lire des bouquins mais faites quelque
chose pour la pour la France parce
qu'aujourd'hui le pays il est dans une
vraie merde et je peux vous dire que je
vois de plus en plus de gens qui sont
dans des difficultés que je n'ai jamais
vu actuellement il y a un énorme
problème et Alexandre aussi un relais
social c'est-à-dire que
on a une activité d'entreprise 20
salariés pour moi des familles derrière
mais faut savoir que il y a pas une
simple économie quand les gens viennent
nous voir dans un bar c'est pour passer
un bon moment c'est pour pour on dit
toujours que le bar et l'étape avant le
psy c'est ça chez nous c'est l'étape
avant le psy aujourd'hui on va plus
personne dans les bars alors pour
Castaldi le bar c'était l'étape après le
divorce
aujourd'hui moi
en créant le le schéma de terreur c'est
un mot peut-être un peu gros mais le
schéma
ils ont réussi à mettre à peu près 30%
de gens dans la rue en moi aujourd'hui
parce que les gens ont peur les gens ont
eu peur de manifester comme ils ont peur
d'aller au bistrot faut pas croire parce
que quand on voit ce qui se passe chez
opéra la semaine dernière
ceux qui travaillent dans le quartier
bon la limite qui savent que c'est pas
tous les jours mais vous rendez compte
le nombre d'annulations de touristes qui
a eu a bien sûr les gens même le prince
Charles annuler le prince Charles a
annulé
non vous avez été menacé par des jeunes
pareil on a été menacé ouais pourquoi de
quoi comment menacer c'est-à-dire bon
après ils sont très jeunes très très
jeunes
il faut le savoir c'est aussi d'ailleurs
on a tendance à dire que c'est toujours
les mêmes qui cassent tout
tous les mêmes questions moi les jeunes
que j'ai vu devant mon bar en train de
brûler les poubelles d'incendie la
boulangerie
de casser tout ce qui pouvait casser
d'essayer de déterrer ce qui pouvait
déterrer c'est des gens comme ça des
gens de quoi
c'est gauche c'est des casseurs c'est ce
que disent les Géraldine à la fois
alors c'est c'est pas du tout les gens
qu'on pourrait retrouver à la sortie
d'un stade de foot une mauvaise
rencontre
par exemple en disant on les voit plus
à Londres je vois ça je viens pas je
suis désolé c'est exactement je vais
vous dire tous les étrangers qui voient
ce qui se passe actuellement en France
ils ont l'impression que là c'est c'est
je vous dis ils en France
on va avoir des dizaines de de guérilla
vous avez perdu 50% de votre chiffre
d'affaires minimum
moi ça fait 11 ans que je suis là
ce que tu as essayé de mettre de côté
pendant 11 ans tu
déjà tu essaies d'économiser pour payer
tes factures d'énergie
puis là le télétravail qui s'est mis en
place après le covid bien sûr si la
nouvelle la nouvelle tendance et les
bistrots ça bah à quoi risqué de prendre
un papier sur la tête et déjà donc là tu
as dû aller chercher dans tes réserves
pour l'électricité au départ parce que
forcément quand elle a la faculté
parce que maintenant les chercher quoi
ah c'est ça un moment bah tu vas
chercher l'espoir l'espoir que ça
reprenne on dit toujours mais ça va
passer non ça passe pas
ça peut se débattre et d'un autre côté
on est dans l'extrême casse dans
l'extrême violence j'en voulais à
l'extrême gauche j'ai l'impression non
non c'est un constat
un peu alors
les mêmes qui cassent donc je prends un
peu
les mecs il y a pas de voilà c'est ça
c'est moi le moins les racailles moi je
voilà c'est vrai que c'est un mot que je
j'emploie j'emploie pas parce que je
n'aime pas j'aime pas ce mot mais il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent les
paillettes les banlieues non ne sont pas
dans les sémaphnifs et aujourd'hui
il y a pas eu de exactement non mais
c'est important de le dire donc c'est
important
c'est tout à fait c'est des casques
politiques
ils aident beaucoup de monde également
et ils sont pas que là voilà non mais
c'est important de le dire mais c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de casses
politiques dans ces manifestations et
Géraldine disait la dernière fois que
voilà
un discours de certaines personnes
d'extrême gauche peuvent également
alimenter
la haine et la violence qu'il y a dans
danser rassemblements pour y revenir si
tu rejoins pas le mouvement bah attends
toi peut-être ta vitrines descend d'un
jour ou l'autre quoi en gros oui c'est
quoi
un débat sur le trottoir très cordial à
la fin voilà il vous faut comprendre que
bon
si les commerçants aujourd'hui ne
rejoignent pas le mouvement bah faudra
pas s'étonner de prendre des papiers
dans la vitrine quoi en gros c'est ça
c'est ça moi j'ai pas le temps de me
rejoindre le mouvement je suis désolé
avec ce qui se passe j'ai pas le temps
déjà hein